going to thank you let's go over now to
Gaza where we understand the health
Ministry is giving a statement let's
listen
in2 children still buried under the
debris the Israeli occupation forces
against violations against the
paramedics resulted in the death of
136 paramedics the total Destruction of
25 ambulance
Vehicles 12 6 hospitals were targeted 16
are
totally of operations and other 50
medical
centers as we speak the Israeli
occupation forces
continue denying the departure of
victims with critical conditions to
leave towards RAF border crossing
although the Egyptian authorities have
allowed the exit of a number of
critically wounded victims as we
appreciate the move taken by the
Egyptians however those victims cannot
depart either from here
towards the
South or to
depart through the border
crossing this move requires Collective
efforts by number of parties in order to
be followed by similar moves we need at
least to have
800 victims with critical conditions or
complicated conditions to leave we
cannot medically attend those cases here
within Gaza Strip hospitals already
collapsing hospitals as a result over
the past few days we lost many victims
who were critically
wounded ala hospital and the Indonesian
hosp the key generators have come to a
stop now we are working on secondary
generators where only three critical
Services can be sustained this is the
Intensive Care
units baby own
incubators and surgical operation rooms
the remaining units and Wards of the
hospitals remain without
electricity during this critical time
the health ministry as we are running
totally out of
fuel we will
continue
to make maximum
efforts to keep the supporting and
secondary
stations working like the pulmonary uh
respiratory devices and other supportive
devices they will be operated on
temporary basis only four hours per
day once again we call on all the
parties the International Community the
international
agency to act swiftly to have Al shifa
complex and the Indonesian hospitals be
supplied with fuel otherwise even the
secondary generators will come to a stop
at that point it is total
disaster we call on the president
government and people of turkey to
provide protection to the Turkish
Hospital the only Hospital catering to
cancer patient in Gaza it is totally out
of operation due to the absence of fuel
we call on the Turkish president to
provide protection to the hospital
ensure the delivery of fuel and save
10,000 cancer patients as we speak we
have lost a dozen of
them simply because the Turkish hospital
has come out of operation we call on all
the parties the International Community
to have a safe Corridor opened for the
delivery of medical
supplies fuel also allowing the
volunteer Medical Teams from outside to
enter and lend a helping
hand we assure our
people and we call on our people to
approach the nearest hospital or Medical
Center to donate
blood we call on the International Red
Cross to provide
with blood quantities in order to lend a
helping hand to us help Saving Lives May
God accept in his Mercy the Fallen
Martyrs Grant speed recovery to the
wounded long live
9,227 the latest figure of those killed
in Israel offensive on Gaza the health
Ministry official there also pointing
out that those casualties include
136 paramedics let's bring back in
mahjub zi he's director of the studies
Center and professor of contemporary
Middle East politics at Kut University
good to have you back with us so
listening to that plea there where he
said we we're calling on the
International Community to provide us
immediately with fuel he said that the
shiffer hospital the Indonesian Hospital
they're working on secondary generators
at this point for only 4 hours a day it
sounds like they're on the CP of a very
grave situation becoming even darker
it's very sad to hear all of this facts
from Gaza and from professional this is
not a political statement he's a doctor
he's he's he's a professional and he's
basically setting the facts that there
is a serious uh uh crisis and we are
beyond the crisis actually um I think
what's interesting about the number of
of killed people in Gaz
it's Sami 80 it represents only
88% of those who were killed um in
Ukrainian War Ukrainian Russia War where
the West have a an alliance and
coalitions to defend that case it's very
sad to see all of this about what's
happened in Ukraine and leave all of
those people to be killed in Gaza with
22,000 people injured in Gaza I think
the issue about fuel it's it's an urgent
matter now for one week International
Community is not acting is not doing any
enough effort to pressure the Israeli
government on on that point though I'm
sure caught your attention as well his
call on Tura yes the Republic the
country to provide protection yes now
that there have been signals from anchor
about a guardian ship I think a call for
a guardianship Arrangement is this put
put the pieces together for us this
going anywhere yeah I mean Turkish
president have made a very clear um
statement where he said um we have sent
medical support we have sent um uh cars
we have sent medicines um and everything
some of these is already in in inish in
in Egypt and he was pushing Egypt to
help to push to push all of this inside
uh Gaza I think the problem as has been
said in the last few days is the
bureaucracy on the borders between Egypt
and Gaza and uh uh uh intervention of
Israelis to check in every small thing
or detail come into Gaza and that that
basically cause more problems to the
government there are reports about a lot
of medicine are expired now there are
some medicine needs um fridge they need
some uh facilities they already they
cannot they cannot basically protect
them I think the issue now is they talk
about Turkish Hospital because it's the
only Hospital take care of the cancer
cases and already um it's important
already four cases has you know have
have killed because of lack um of of
resources all right all right thanks so
much M zi for joining us